- C'est la nuit de dimanche
à l'urgence...
- Une menace qui semble
avoir porté fruit.
Devant la possibilité de refus
de faire des heures
supplémentaires obligatoires
en fin de semaine,
les établissements de santé
concernés ont mis
les bouchées doubles.
LAURIER OUELLET, prés.Syndicat
prof. en soins Chaudière-Appa.
- Hier soir, il y avait eu très
peu de temps supplémentaires.
Cette nuit, on a eu quatre temps
supplémentaires dans tout
Chaudière-Appalaches.
- Dans les dix CISSS et CIUSSS
ainsi qu'au CHU de Québec,
le fameux TSO a baissé
radicalement.
STEPHANE CORMIER, président du
Syndicat santé de Lanaudière
- Le plus difficile de remplir
les trous, c'est les fins de
semaine. Si tu es capable
de faire un samedi-dimanche
en boucle, tu peux le faire
tout le temps.
- Le CIUSSS de la Capitale-
Nationale et de la Mauricie-
Centre-du-Québec ont mobilisé
leurs cadres pour pallier
la pénurie de personnel.
La question est sérieuse. Le TSO
fait fuir les infirmières.
- Si on m'impose un temps
supplémentaire obligatoire,
je quitte. Et si la situation
ne s'améliore pas, je suis prête
à quitter le réseau,
c'est décidé.
- C'est pourquoi La FIQ est
en guerre ouverte contre le TSO.
Mises en demeure envoyées
au gouvernement, aux pdg
des établissments fautifs et
même aux ordres professionels.
Elle demande l'aide de la CNESST
et de la Commission des droits
de la personne.
Le ministre Christian Dubé veut
lui aussi enrayer cette pratique
au sein des établissements, mais
encore faut-il du personnel.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre
de la Santé du Québec
- Mais je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'en veux plus
du TSO.
ROXANE BORGES DA SILVA,, prof.
École santé publique, UdeM
- C'est que tant qu'on a pas
assez de monde pour couvrir
tous les quarts de travail,
bien, on n'a pas le choix
d'utiliser ces mécanismes
qui sont très négatifs.
- Il y a 4 000 infimières et
infirmières auxiliaires qui
travaillent dans les agences
privées. Le gouvernement, il est
capable de prendre le monopole
de la SAQ, de la SQDC,
d'Hydro-Québec, des casinos;
pourquoi il ne prend pas
le monopole en santé?
- Il manque plus de 5500
infirmières et infimières
auxiliaires à temps complet
dans le réseau, sans compter
celles non vaccinées qui seront
suspendus à la mi-novembre.
- Et en mettant en demeure
le ministre de la Santé à ce
moment-là qui est un moment
très stratégique et très précis
où on va avoir besoin de nos
travailleurs de la santé pour
s'assurer d'avoir une qualité
et une sécutité des soins
optimales, la FIQ se met dans
une position un peu maladroite.
- La FIQ donne jusqu'au
15 novembre au gouvernement
pour mettre fin aux heures
supplémentaires obligatoires.
Cet ultimatum coincide avec
la nouvelle date de suspension
des employés non-vaccinés.
Sans ses employés et sans TSO,
le réseau pourraient faire face
à de nombreux bris de services.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette Comeau
Radio-Canada, Montréal.